تجمع الطلاب في تايلاند للتجمع في
أول يوم لهم بعد عودتهم إلى المدرسة منذ
منتصف مارس ،
وهناك قواعد جديدة يجب أن تتماشى مع
التعليم العادي الجديد في وقت الإصابة بالفيروس التاجي
أولاً ،
مجموعة مضخة من معقم اليدين
وواقي للوجه بالكامل وفحص درجة الحرارة
والفصل الدراسي
عاد إلى الجلسة أحد الدروس الأولى لهذه المجموعة حول
كيفية الحفاظ على
مقصورات مؤقتة مصنوعة من
صناديق اقتراع قديمة
تساعد على إبقاء الطلاب منفصلين ،
تقول إحدى الفتيات إنها تشعر بالرضا عن الدراسة
خلف الصندوق
، مما يجعلها تشعر بالأمان بالعودة إلى
المدرسة
قبل إعادة فتحها في تايلاند
احتواء الفيروس بشكل فعال ،
لا يزال معدل الإصابة به منخفضًا ما يزيد قليلاً عن
3200 حالة مؤكدة
على الرغم من أنها كانت أول دولة
خارج
الصين تكتشف حالة كوفيد 19. تغلق مدارس هونغ كونغ
مرة أخرى ، حيث استأنفت أيضًا بدء الدراسة قبل
شهر ونصف
بسبب  ارتفاع جديد في الحالات التي
قرر المسؤولون بدء العطلة الصيفية
مبكرًا ، فأنا على وشك التعليق على أحد الطلاب
يقول
إنه انتهى لتوه من امتحاناته  لم يكن هناك
سوى أسبوع واحد آخر من الفصول الدراسية ليذهب إليها ،
لذا لم يكن هناك فرق كبير ،
فقد كانت هناك عمليات تراجع مماثلة في
بكين
وأجزاء من أستراليا حيث
فتح المسؤولون المدارس بعد إغلاق يبدو أنه
ناجحًا
فقط لإغلاقها مرة أخرى بعد
اندلاع  فيروس كورونا
في المناطق الساخنة العالمية مثل أمريكا الجنوبية ،
يتم إغلاق آلاف الحالات الجديدة كل يوم المدارس مع استثناءات قليلة ،
وقد عاد معظم طلاب أوروغواي
إلى الفصل
الدراسي ، وأغلق حدوده مبكرًا ولديه
حوالي ألف حالة إجمالية
على عكس جارتها البرازيل الأكبر والأكثر كثافة.
ربما تكون المسافة البعيدة لجزيرة الفصح في تشيلي قد جنّتها من مصير مدرسة
البر الرئيسي
التي استؤنفت مؤخرًا هناك ،
يقول أحد الطلاب إنها فرصة
مُنحت لهم
لأنه في القارة لم يكن من الممكن
العودة إلى الفصل الدراسي بسبب
الوباء
هناك فرصة للبلدان المجاورة
العالم يكافح من
أجل إدارته بينما تتعلم المدارس حتى بعد
إعادة فتح أبوابها ،
لا توجد ضمانات بأن الفيروس قد انتصر ''  ر
العودة